THE OTHER CHANCE LET YOU GET
AWAY WITH.
YOU ARE EXPLOIT A WOMAN AND YOU
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF IT.
THIS IS AN ATTORNEY WORKING FOR
ONE OF CREEPY PORN LAWYER'S
FORMER CLIENTS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU TELL US WHAT
ABOUT HIS BEHAVIOR IN YOUR VIEW
WARRANTS DISBARMENT?
>> WELL, MY VIEW SHAPED BY 30
YEARS AS A LAWYER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE BEEN A JUDGE AND A
PROSECUTOR.
OVER THE LAST 10 YEARS IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE.
THE LEGAL PROFESSION MEANS THE
WORLD TO ME.
AT THE CORE OF THE LEGAL
PROFESSION IS HONESTY, TRUST,
AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO OUR
CLIENTS.
TO SOMEONE TO DO WHAT
MR. AVANATI IS ACCUSED OF DOING
BY THE STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA
AND TWO U.S. ATTORNEY OFFICES
THREATENS THE RULE OF LAW.
>> Tucker: IT THREATENS TO SHAPE
THE PUBLIC'S VIEW OF YOUR
PROFACS.
-- PROFESSION.
WHY HASN'T HE BEEN DISBARRED
ALREADY?
>> OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM DEPENDS ON
THE PROCESS.
MR. AVANATI HASN'T BEEN
CONVICTED.
HE HASN'T BEEN FOUND GUILTY.
BUT THIS WEEK THE STATE BAR OF
CALIFORNIA FILED PAPERS SEEKING
TO HAVE HIM MOVED TO AN
INVOLUNTARY INACTIVE STATUS.
THEY CAN ONLY DO THAT WHEN THEY
HAVE CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE HE IS A THREAT TO THE
PUBLIC AND HIS CLIENTS.
THEY BELIEVE THEY WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL AND THAT WILL LEAD TO
DISBARMENT.
IT'S AN UNUSUAL STEP TO TAKE.
IT'S WORKING THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
OUR RULE OF LAW IS PEOPLE ARE
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY.
WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT WILL
HAPPEN BUT WE NEED TO AWAY THE
PROCESS.
>> Tucker: HAS HE EVER HAD ANY
DEFENSE?
>> NONE.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING COME
FORWARD.
HE'S HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO.
WE BROUGHT AN ARBITRATION
PROCEEDING AND WANTED TO HAVE
THE ARBITRATION.
IT REQUIRED HIM TO PAY THE
ARBITRATION FEES WHICH HE
REFUSED TO DO.
WE ARE PLANING TO DISMISS THAT
AND MOVE FORWARD IN THE STATE
COURT WHICH IS OUR RIGHT TO DO.
HE IS DOING EVERYTHING HE CAN TO
DELAY THIS.
IT'S WITHIN HIS RIGHTS BUT WE
ARE CONVINCED THAT JUSTICE WILL
PREVAIL.
>> Tucker: YOU SEEM LIKE A MAN
OF INTEGRITY AND BEEN A
PROSECUTOR AND JUDGE AND PRIVATE
PRACTICE ATTORNEY.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T LIKE LAWYERS
NOT BECAUSE OF PEOPLE LIKE YOU
BUT BECAUSE OF PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
THERE ARE A LOT OF SLEAZY
LAWYERS AND ALMOST NONE EVER GET
DISBARRED.
DO STATE BAR ASSOCIATIONS, WHY
DON'T THEY DO SOMETHING TO
IMPROVE THE GUILT OF LAWYERS?
MAYBE THAT WOULD HELP ALL
LAWYERS.
>> WELL, THERE NO QUESTION WE AS
LAWYERS REGULATE OURSELVES TO A
LARGE EXTENT.
WE ARE A SELF-REGULATING
PROFESS.
ION.
WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF LAWYERS ARE
COMMITTED TO THE RULE OF LAW.
WITH YOU GIVEN THE SENSITIVITY
OF THE POSITION AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE POSITION OF
LAWYERS, A FEW BAD APPLES CAN